this next clip is hilarious we are
seeing the equivalent
of competing temper tantrums happening
right now
right-wing media that's loyal to trump
is having a temper tantrum as they
realize
trump's going to leave office trump lost
joe biden won
none of these ridiculous attempts to
steal the election are going to work so
that's one temper tantrum
on the other side meanwhile you have
some trump advisors
increasingly having a temper tantrum
that more and more media
are acknowledging that trump won you
understand the competing
temper tantrums here and the day before
yesterday
this came together and it was just
glorious i mean this is it this is a
pleasure to watch and it was made
even better by a slight connection delay
between the two people involved and this
was a conversation between
fox business host lou dobbs and
huge who by the way is a huge trumpist
himself
and then radical unhinged extremist
trump advisor
stephen miller so check out this clip
and what it seems like is happening here
is lou dobbs is mad at republicans for
not
standing behind trump and not fighting
more
fighting to steal an election that trump
lost by the way
and stephen miller is mad apparently at
states and governors
when they seem to then start getting mad
at each other
the connection delay makes it even
funnier lou dobbs seems mad at stephen
miller
and it's just a complete fiasco and this
is truly people who have no idea what to
do
they're falling apart like a kid who
missed their nap take a look at this
republicans do
nothing stephen nothing it's it's
it's what's wrong with the republican
party
where is the outrage really tens of
millions
tens of millions of the hell are the
republicans no signatures
the hell are the republicans
you're right tens of millions of ballots
nationwide no signature checks
no citizenship checks no residency
checks no age checks
no criminal record checks not even
checking if you're alive or dead
now of course what stephen miller is
saying is absurd
no we're not checking if people are
alive you can't vote if you're dead
physically you can't do it
no citizenship check you can't even
register to vote if you're not a citizen
these are the same old tired talking
points
that they keep using and this
conversation kept
escalating as lou dobbs claims
republicans have abandoned donald trump
take a look
are we a third world country are we a
banana republic
what does it come to it only legal
balance
from u.s citizens let me tell you what
it is president gets four more years
let me uh and and you know from your
lips to god's ears
uh the reality is that this president
right now
is fighting and let's be straightforward
about it he's
fighting all along and ted cruz has
stepped up to say he'll argue before the
supreme court
why in god's green earth wouldn't the
white house jump on it
why shouldn't they accept that right now
and i'll just say this one other thing
though if three state legislatures i
just outlined
one correction i won't let you say
i'm not going to let you do that i'm not
going to let you do that i ask a
question
you and i we're reasonably smart and
decent fellows
they are reasonably smart and decent
they just want
an election that joe biden won to be
overturned
without evidence and given to the man
they worship these are guys
these are recent reasonably smart and
decent people who just want
the democratic process thrown in the
toilet and trump awarded a victory
they just disagree about how to do it
lou dobbs is mad at republican senators
while i guess stephen miller is mad at
republican governors
but now lou dobbs demands an answer from
stephen miller
why don't you hire ted cruz as a lawyer
to fight this battle
why don't you answer me that's all i'm
asking here stephen
why don't you guys jump and salute ted
cruz
and say yes we want you on the team now
my god this is not a time for
internecine
nonsense on the part of the republican
party which is watching its blood
drain into the streets because they're
got
consider how absurd lou dobbs idea is
to hire ted cruz as a lawyer
to steal the election hire a sitting
senator
to also be a lawyer from the for the
pres it's just a farcical idea
and it's actually funny because lou i
don't know if you saw but lou dobbs did
something there that's rarely done
on right-wing media to trump advisers
and trump sycophants
lou dobbs interrupted stephen miller and
said you're not answering the question
so this proves what we suspected which
is they do
know these journalists do know how to do
it
but they're choosing not to unless they
don't like the answer
lou dobbs in this case didn't like the
answer so we're seeing everything
in the last few weeks we're seeing some
rats abandoning the ship
and sort of eating each other on the way
out we're seeing some rats go down with
the ship kaylee mckennony
would be an example of that um you're
seeing people who are going the
direction of
sort of like pretending none of this
ever happened and uh it it really is
like the best comedy team
on television you know rudy gets covid
put ted cruz
on the case it's laughable and hilarious
and it will be over soon i'm not here to
tell you help is on the way that's not
my catchphrase
it will be over soon as the catchphrase
that uh that i'm going with here
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even auto fill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com pacman